so we've been hearing for a while that
the Hulk is going to be getting his own
Solo movie this movie is most likely
going to be a World War Hulk movie and
we have some really good news for Hulk
fans I'm not talking Professor Hulk fans
I'm talking true Savage can't control
his anger rageful radioactive Hulk
because we are going to be getting that
Hulk back in the MCU and pretty soon the
Hulk is going to once again become one
of the main lead characters of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Marvel Studios
has been making a ton of changes
recently and you've probably heard about
a decent amount of these changes that
are coming to the MCU or are happening
right now the Daredevil series was not
cancelled just want to clarify that once
again because there seems to be some
confusion out there and some people seem
to think that Daredevil born again the
entire Series has been cancelled it has
not been cancelled they are simply in a
way kind of starting over they're going
to rewrite the series basically Vincent
denafo says that he's not concerned and
that it should be better The Hollywood
Reporter also adds that Marvel does plan
to keep some of the scenes and episodes
in Daredevil born again since there were
18 episodes but they do have new writers
and new executive producers now and one
of the big changes that Marvel has made
is they are actually dividing these 18
episodes into two different seasons but
still going to be one season according
to The Insider can we get some toast
they're going to have a season 1A and
then 9 to 12 months later release the
other Nine episodes as a season 1B so
just one example of the big changes that
Marvel Studios is making and again one
of the bigger changes has to do with the
Hulk unfortunately due to the rights
issues that Marvel Studios had with
universal they could never make a solo
Hulk film and a new book was recently
released called MCU the reign of Marvel
Studios and this book talks about all of
the inside information of Marvel Studios
it gives us a lot of juicy details of
what happened internally throughout a
lot of the infinity Saga and basically
what has happened up until now the
authors of this book interviewed over a
hundred different people who worked with
or around Marvel Studios to learn all of
these details and what we've learned is
that moving forward in the MCU Kevin
fagy knew they had to put the focus on
some main Heroes Tom Holland Spider-Man
was one of those Heroes Brie larsson's
Captain Marvel was one of those Heroes
and Chadwick boseman's tala black
panther was one of those Heroes now
unfortunately of course Chadwick Boseman
passed away so black panther could not
be one of the main prominent characters
of the MCU and unfortunately even though
they wanted to neither could the Hulk
the Hulk because of the rights issues
could not be one of the main characters
and focuses of the MCU moving forward
because they couldn't ever do a solo
Hulk project whether that be a movie or
Disney Plus show that's why Thor
Ragnarok was essentially a Thor and a
Hulk film because he could not have his
own Hulk film that's also why we saw him
in She-Hulk but clearly Marvel Studios
does have a story plan for him since he
went back to SAR and came back with his
son Scar and this all is leading to a
setup for his own Solo movie and now
thankfully Marvel Studios does have the
rights for the Hulk back so now they can
do whatever they want and we know a
little bit about what they are planning
one is hopefully he does become a pretty
big character in the MCU now he is one
of the OG Avengers and Kevin FY the
president of Marvel Studios knows that
fans are waiting for him to Hulk out
again and here's what is being said said
recently from some insiders about the
future of the Hulk Joanna Robinson who
is one of the writers of MCU the reign
of Marvel Studios said this Marvel had a
plan they're like we know we're losing
our Varsity players we know they're
leaving so they're seating in Paul Rudd
and Benedict Cumberbatch they put
Chadwick Boseman in a really prominent
important place they put Brie Larson in
so this is talking about what I just
mentioned Marvel Studios was setting up
other prominent characters in the MCU to
play really important roles because they
were losing Iron Man Captain America
Black Widow big hitters basically but
the Hulk was not mentioned due to the
rights however Insider can we get some
toast recently came out in response to
this and tweeted this Mark ruffalo's
Bruce Banner Hulk is a bit of a
different story Kevin fige is conscious
of how the right situation with Hulk
always kept him as more of a supporting
character rather than one of the mains
with everything Marvel has set up in
She-Hulk and Captain America Brave New
World there's definitely a plan in place
for more Hulk in the mcu's future so
Marvel Studios got the rights back to
the Hulk and basically said he's got to
be a big hitter too he's got to play a
prominent role in the MCU because we
know fans love him and as far as Savage
Hulk coming back this is what can we get
some toast said not too long ago Savage
Hulk's rage has been festering what
happens when SM Hulk loses himself to
his rage so basically Hulk is going to
Hulk out again and could possibly Hulk
out bigger than we've ever seen before
for because we know that Savage Hulk has
been inside of Professor Hulk for years
now we know that he's been let's just
say suppressed throughout the entirety
of the events of Avengers endgame maybe
not through the entirety fiveyear jump
to the Future Gap that we had in
Avengers endgame but at some point time
in that Gap Bruce Banner created a way
to make Professor Hulk and of course we
saw him and She-Hulk and he was
Professor Hulk the entire time so he's
been Professor Hulk for years now so
that means the Hulk has been sitting
inside getting angrier and angrier that
he couldn't be leted out yes in Avengers
Infinity War he didn't want to come out
to save the day but that was his own
choice Professor Hulk was Banner's
choice and the real Hulk didn't really
have a say in that so that was kind of
against his will which of course would
make him angry now we've been told that
we are going to be getting a World War
Hulk movie which you automatically would
assume we're going to get a crazy
rageful and insanely powerful Hulk well
according to the Insiders this is still
the plan for the Hulk to get his own
Solo movie in response to can we get
some toast stating that Marvel does have
plans for Bruce Banner's Hulk Insider my
time to shine hello said this we are
getting a solo Hulk movie and Hulk will
be in Kang Dynasty now we kind of know
what the Hulk movie is somewhat going to
be about because like can we get some
toast said Captain America 4 Brave New
World is going to involve the super
soldier serum greatly in fact it sounds
like based off of what we've heard this
is going to be such a problem to some of
the Avengers that A Min Avengers team is
going to go up against Thunderbolt Ross
and it sounds like Hulk is going to be
one of those people now as far as what
world war Hulk is going to be about once
Captain America 4 comes we know that
we'll essentially have four hulks in the
MCU we'll have She-Hulk Red Hulk Hulk's
son Scar and of course the Hulk himself
plus not to mention any other hulks that
might come out of Captain America 4 and
unfortunately when they say a World War
Hulk movie I don't think they mean the
world war Hulk comic storyline I think
they mean that there's going to be a war
on Earth with a lot of Hulks in it and I
think it's essentially going to be kind
of our Bruce Banner Hulk leading a good
team of Hulks against a bad team of
Hulks that were created by the super
soldier serum that's kind of what we've
heard before but we do know that Marvel
Studios has been making a lot of changes
recently and a lot of those changes have
actually been with writing and script so
the Hulk movie could be completely
different because I know a lot of people
really do want an uncontrollable Savage
Hulk which is essentially what we got in
the world war Hulk storyline where the
Hulk went on to basically make the
Avengers and the Fantastic Four his
slaves and he made them all fight in a
Coliseum against each other he ruled
over them because he thought that they
were responsible for the death of his
wife and his unborn son so he got so
rageful that he almost broke the Earth
he even ended up defeating centry and at
the end of it all he let Tony Stark use
a device on him to turn him back into
Bruce Banner there's a lot of components
of that that can't happen in the MCU
right now like we don't have the
Fantastic 4 yet or or a main Universe
Illuminati but there's a lot of really
cool components that Marvel Studios
could include from the comics in a world
war Hulk movie if they truly plan for
him to go full Savage Hulk which
according to these insiders that is
what's going to happen so we are getting
a full Savage Hulk once again and we're
going to need him for Kang Dynasty these
Kang variants are going to be no joke
the Council of kangs is going to be no
joke and we know that they're
essentially going to win so Savage Hulk
even though we are very excited for him
probably isn't going to be enough but
nonetheless we will be super excited to
see the Hulk new story in the MCU we'll
be excited to see him become a new
prominent character and be excited to
see Savage Hulk come out once again but
let us know what you are most excited
for in the comments down below and what
would you like to see from a solo Hulk
movie let us know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month don't forget to follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof